the kentucky derby is normally in may
it's in september this year and this was
the mets
watching it just as the game was about
to begin
and i would imagine those boys have the
winners
also who i think most people think
should be a starting pitcher but it just
never has panned out for him
on the long term well reece coming up
hitting 268 with seven home runs 19 runs
batted in he's hitting six straight
that balls hit well out toward left
field going back on it is mcneal
it is gone a first hitting home run for
reese hoskins
his eighth of the year it's his first
hit against lugo and a dozen at bats
and the phillies laid it one-nothing and
they scored a run in
seven consecutive games second inning
one-nothing phillies gene segura leads
off against seth lugo
that's a high fastball to get segura for
his second strikeout
bowman was over four last night with
three strikeouts and he dots the outside
corner to get balm looking
here's neil walker getting his eighth
start of the year
and walker takes strike three called and
lugo strikes out the side
in the second inning four strikeouts for
seth one nothing built
i think that's the difference with with
seth lugo from so many other guys now he
he loves the art of pitching he watched
four phillies games over the last two
days struck him out with the fastball
first time up goes to the curve here and
strikes him out again
so now reese hoskins and he struck him
out so
lugo gets the better of hoskins this
time they'll face rayo muto now with two
out and two on
and rayamuto swings through the fastball
for strike three so for the second
straight inning lugo strikes out three
he's got
seven jeff had an o for four last night
hit the ball
hard a couple times came away empty he
drives this one out to center field
chasing hazley back
and it's over his head and one hop
against the wall
and it goes over the fence it'll be a
ground rule double
so now andres jimenez with a runner at
second
curveball pulled through the hole of
base hit mcneil waved around
30s heading home harper will not make a
throw andres dimenez ties the game with
an rbi single and it's one to one
here's michael conforto with the tying
run at third and two out
and conforto flicks one into left field
that's going to fall for a base hit and
the mitz will take the lead
jimenez comes in to score and conforto
serves one on the left for the go ahead
hit his 25th run batted in and it's 2-1
new york
so now two in scoring position for
andres jimenez who drove in the first
med run with a base hit
and jimenez pops it up shallow right
center
walker out frazier back to 10. and
walker catches about his heels of
frasier will try to score
and he will come home where was harper
harbor's got to catch that ball that is
just
inexcusable i mean did they not remember
there was a runner a third with less
than two out he knew
walker gives harper a look like where
were you
here's hoskins he gets a curveball and
he strikes him out
number eight for lugo tying his career
high
third time through the order changes the
program well when bryce harper came into
the dugout nobody talked to him the
entire length of the dugout until he got
to the veteran jay bruce and
obviously we don't know what jay was
saying but he was the only
person in that phillies dugout who said
anything to bryce harper
neil walker who was the party of the
other part and still doesn't understand
why
bryce didn't call for that ball harper
with two out and nobody on
and he gets a curveball and hits it just
foul harper thought maybe that was a
fair ball
it's not a challengeable call because
the ball was in front
of the base umpire but he stared down at
roberto ortiz the first base umpire
thinking that was a fair ball
close close
i don't think you'd make that reaction
unless you think it went over the bag
right
off lugos bare hand grabbed by frazier
and they get
frey uh harper at first a 1-5-3 put out
to put an end to the top of the fifth
well while we were gone
bryce harper went at it with the first
base umpire roberto ortiz who called his
hard shot over the bag foul and he got
himself ejected from the game
what i thought was happening was he
wanted to talk to him about it i think
the umpire
decided that he did not want to talk to
him about it and i think bryce just
wanted to have a conversation with him
and then when he got thrown out of the
game that's when bryce
became pretty incensed yeah and the
bases are loaded with nobody out and dom
smith coming up ground ball
walker in to get it bobbles it and he'll
get a force at second as a run comes
home
davis had stopped to try to
avoid getting tagged which is why walker
was still able to get an out
but nimmo comes home to make it 4-1 new
york now robinson torinos
will come to bat in the air to right
center field back toward the gap goes
quinn onto the warning track and he
can't make the catch
jimenez breaks for third he's going to
be waved around
and jimenez will score on the double by
robinson chorinos and the mets lead 5-1
so back-to-back walks issued by diaz
opening the door for the phillies here
in the ninth one two
he struck him out and the ball game is
over diaz strikes out three in the ninth
seth lugo gets the victory the first by
a met starter in
20 games and the mets beat the phillies
for the first time this season 5-1